>> Gutfeld: ANTI-SEMITISM TAKES
CRACK AT CHAPPELLE.
DAVE CHAPPELLE HOSTED "SATURDAY
NIGHT LIVE" THIS WEEKEND.
THE SHOW WAS FUNNY.
ALSO, HIS MONOLOGUE IS CALLED
ANTI-SEMITIC BY THE HEAD OF THE
ANTI-DEFAMATION LEAGUE.
GIVING CHAPPELLE MUCH NEEDED
BREAK FROM BEING CALLED
TRANSPHOBIC.
HE DREW IRE WHEN HE JOKED ABOUT
KANYE WEST RECENT ANTI-SEMITIC
REMARKS.
>> THERE ARE TWO WORDS IN THE
ENGLISH LANGUAGE THAT SHOULD
NEVER SAY TOGETHER.
THOSE WORDS ARE THE AND JEWS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
NEVER HEARD SOMEONE DO GOOD
AFTER THEY SAID THAT.
SHOW BUSINESS RULES.
THIS IS THE RULE.
THE RULES OF DECEPTION.
IF THEY ARE BLACK IT'S A GAME.
IF THEY ARE ITALIAN IT'S A MOB.
IF THEY ARE JEWISH IT'S A
COINCIDENCE.
YOU SHOULD NEVER SPEAK ABOUT IT.
>> Gutfeld: THE REST OF THE 15
MINUTE MONOLOGUE WENT THE SAME
WAY.
THIS CAUSE LIBERALS TO CLUTCH
THEIR PEARLS.
HERE'S MORE.
>> I'VE BEEN TO HOLLYWOOD.
I'M JUST TELLING YOU.
THIS IS WHAT I SAW.
IT'S A LOT OF JEWS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
LIKE A LOT.
THAT DON'T MEAN ANYTHING.
THERE'S A LOT OF BLACK PEOPLE IN
FERGUSON, MISSOURI, THAT DOESN'T
MEAN THEY RUN THE PLACE.
>> Gutfeld: HE PULLS YOU IN AND
HE SETS IT STRAIGHT.
DOES HE KNOW THEY WERE JEWISH?
HOW DOES HE KNOW FERGUSON
RESIDENTS JUST SARAH SILVERMAN
AND JIMMY KIMMEL?
NOW YOU'RE AWAKE.
LATER, HE BROUGHT IT ALL BACK TO
KANYE.
>> I CAN SEE IF HE HAD SOME KIND
OF ISSUE.
HE MIGHT GO OUT TO HOLLYWOOD AND
HE MIGHT START CONNECTING SOME
ALLIANCE.
LET THE JEWS RUN SHOW BUSINESS.
NOT A CRAZY THING TO THINK.
IT'S A CRAZY THING TO SAY OUT
LOUD IN A CLIMATE LIKE THIS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> Gutfeld: THE NEXT MORNING,
ADL CEO TWEETED.
DISTURBING TO SEE "SNL" NOT JUST
NORMALIZE BUT POPULARIZE
ANTI-SEMITISM.
WHY IS JEWISH TRAUMA DIMINISHED.
DID CHAPPELLE STEP OVER THE
LINE?
WAS THE ANTI-DEFAMATION LEAGUE
LEADERSHIP TOO SENSITIVE.
HE GOT PEOPLE TO WATCH "SNL" AND
LAUGH.
ROB, YOU WERE SAYING IN THE
GREEN ROOM THAT, OF COURSE THE
JEWS RUN HOLLYWOOD.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> THAT WAS EXACTLY WHAT I WAS
SAYING.
>> Gutfeld: WE GOT TO GO TO
BREAK.
>> I WILL SAY THIS.
BLACK MEN HAVE BEEN GETTING IN
LOT OF TROUBLE FOR THIS WHOLE
THING LATELY.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS SEGMENT
IDENTIFIES ASIANS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I AM ASIAN FOR FIVE MORE
MINUTES.
WHEN IT COMES TO THIS -- YOU
KNOW, KANYE LOST $1 BILLION OF
HIS NET WORTH.
THAT HAPPENED TO ME, I WILL BE
-- WHAT I WILL SAY, I THINK THAT
WHAT CHAPPELLE GREAT AT IS
MAKING US UNCOMFORTABLE THROUGH
HUMOR.
MY THING WITH THESE OFF COLOR
HUMOR, IT CAN'T BE RACIST,
SEXIST, HOMOPHOBIC, ANTI-SEMITIC
IF I LAUGHED.
>> Gutfeld: YOU'RE SAYING FUNNY
OVERRIDES EVERYTHING.
>> THERE USED TO BE A COMEDIAN
WHO TOLD THE CRAZIEST RACIST
JOKESES.
I ALWAYS LAUGHED.
>> Gutfeld: SHE WAS AMAZING ON
THOSE ROASTS.
DID SHE PASS AWAY?
>> I THINK SHE'S STILL AROUND.
I WAS NEVER OFFENDED.
SHE NEVER TOLD ANY ANTI-ASIAN
JOKES.  I HOPE THAT MY PEOPLE --
>> Gutfeld: I HOPE YOUR PEOPLE
CAN OVERCOME THIS.
MORGAN, YOU'RE JEWISH?
CORRECT?
>> YES.
>> Gutfeld: MORGAN, YOU ARE
JEWISH.
BEFORE HE STARTED HIS MONOLOGUE,
CHAPPELLE READ A STATEMENT
DENOUNCING ANTI-SEMITISM.
DID THAT NOT MATTER?
>> HE'S MY FAVORITE COMEDIAN OF
ALL-TIME.
AFTER YOU, OF COURSE.
HE'S THE GUY THAT -- HE'S THE
COMEDIAN THAT CAME UP ABOUT BACK
BUSH DURING THE HEIGHT OF THE
IRAQ WAR.
I THINK THERE'S A BIG DIFFERENCE
INTENT.
HE WAS BEING FUNNY.
KANYE WAS BEING A [ BLEEP ].
IT WASN'T FUNNY.  HE WAS MAKING
FUN OF EVERYONE.
HE MADE FUN OF HERSCHEL WALKER.
WE NEED TO LIGHTEN UP.
THERE'S LOTS OF REAL
ANTI-SEMITISM IN THE WORLD.
>> Gutfeld: WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I APPLAUD.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> APPLAUD THE JEWISH WOMAN.
LET'S GO TO YOU, CAT.
RAISED CATHOLIC?
POLISH?
>> YES.
>> Gutfeld: THOUGHTS?
>> I THINK THAT ALL THE ARTICLES
ABOUT THIS, THEY WROTE BEFORE HE
DID IT.
THEY REPLACED TRANSPHOBIC WITH
ANTI-SEMITIC.
HE'S MAKING JOKES.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE
ANTI-DEFAMATION LEAGUE, THIS
ISN'T REALLY NEW.
THEY HAD A PROBLEM WITH JONE
RIVERS YEARS AGO REFERENCING THE
HOLOCAUST IN A JOKE.
JONE RIVERS IS ANTI-SEMITIC,
SHE'S TERRIBLE AT IT.
>> Gutfeld: I KNOW SHE IS DEAD.
>> SHE IS DEAD.
HER LATE HUSBAND LOST ALL OF HIS
FAMILY IN THE HOLOCAUST.
WHEN IT COMES TO JOKES, IT'S
REALLY NOT THAT SERIOUS.
JOKING IS THE OPPOSITE OF
SERIOUS.
>> Gutfeld: HOW CAN A JOKE BE
DEFAMATION IF IT'S A JOKE?
WHY IS THE ANTI-DEFAMATION
WASTING THEIR TIME CHASING A
JOKE WHEN THEY SHOULD BE --
YOU'RE NOT THE ANTI-JOKE LEAGUE.
YOU'RE ANTI-DEFAMATION LEAGUE.
I SAVED THE JOKE FOR LAST SEASON
PROFESSIONAL COMEDIAN.
MAKES PEOPLE LAUGH ACROSS THE
COUNTRY OVER THE GLOBE.
>> I'M THE SECOND FAVORITE
COMEDIAN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
CHAPPELLE USED LOT OF NUANCE.
HE SAID HE THOUGHT KANYE WAS NOT
WELL WHEN HE MADE THOSE
STATEMENTS.
COMEDIANS EXAGGERATE AND SAY
THINGS THEY DON'T THINK ARE
TRUE.
WHEN HE SAID THAT KANYE GOT IN
SO MUCH TROUBLE, HE GOT KYRIE IN
TROUBLE.
KYRIE GOT IN TROUBLE ON HIS OWN.
I DO THAT ALL THE TIME.
I HAD A JOKE ABOUT HOW --
>> Gutfeld: EXECUTE MORE WOMEN.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT'S TRUE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> Gutfeld: YOU GOT NOTHING
AGAINST WOMEN.
I WANT TO PLAY THIS ONE SOT THE
THING WHERE HE TALKED ABOUT
TRUMP.
YOU CAN HEAR A PIN DROP.
>> REASON HE'S LOVE BECAUSE
PEOPLE IN OHIO NEVER SEEN
SOMEBODY LIKE HIM.
NEVER SEEN WHITE MALE
BILLIONAIRE SCREAMING AT THE TOP
OF THE LUNG.
HIS WHOLE SYSTEM IS RIGGED.
ACROSS THE STAGE WAS WHITE WOMAN
HILLARY CLINTON AND BARACK OBAMA
SAYING, NO IT'S NOT.
HE SAID I KNOW THE SYSTEM IS
RIGGED, BECAUSE I USE IT.
WITH THAT MY FRIENDS, THE STAR
WAS BORN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> Gutfeld: I DON'T THINK THE
AUDIENCE WANTED TO HEAR THAT.
HE UNDERSTOOD.
HE CAN TAKE YOU TO THE MIDDLE OF
A PROBLEM AND ALMOST GET PEOPLE
DIFFERENT SIDES TO AGREE.
I'M KIND OF LIKE THAT.
>> I'M ACTUALLY SHOCKED THAT A
LIBERAL AUDIENCE AT "SNL" IN NEW
YORK CITY DID NOT LIKE THAT
JOKE.
LITERALLY.
>> Gutfeld: I WI